The answer is the first two. The first one is checking the signature.
We're checking the signature here by decrypting using the public key
that verifies that this message was created by someone who knows the private key
so we verify the signature, and you might think that would be enough.
We verify the signature, we obtain the public key, and we obtain the value
that we need to produce our Diffie-Hellman key.
The reason that's not enough is because we're also worried about replay attacks,
and that's why we need to do the second check.
We're going to recompute this hash. Note that the hash is one way.
We can't use the hash to learn the key, but we can compute the key like this for the client
and then check that the key and the hash matches that.
By computing the hash, we know that there is no replay attack because these values are fresh.
If there was a replay attack and a different hash value was replayed,
then this hash wouldn't match, so we need both of those.
The third check doesn't make sense, and this uses Yc as well as Xs,
which is the secret value of the server.
If that was revealed, that would break the protocol.